♪ ♪
>> THE BIG FOCUS FOR US IS
FINDING OUT HOW OUR ADVERSARIES
ARE USING BIG DATA AGAINST US.
>> FOREIGN ACTORS WILL BE THE
2020 U.S. ELECTIONS AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ADVANCE THEIR
INTERESTS.
>> I THINK CHINA AT LARGE IS THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE THREAT WE
FACE.
>> THE UNDERLYING POLITICAL AND
ECONOMIC FACTORS THAT
FACILITATED THE RISE OF ISIS
PROCESSED.
>> THERE IS STILL A SUBSTANTIAL
MILITARY CAPACITY THAT
KIM JONG UN WIELDS PEER TO THE
IRANIANS ARE CONSIDERING TAKING
STEPS THAT WOULD LESSEN THEIR
ADHERENCE.
>> Bret: IT IS ALWAYS
INTERESTING, THOUGH THREAT
ASSESSMENT, THE INTELLIGENCE
LEADERS FOR THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION TALKING ABOUT
THREATS FROM AROUND THE WORLD.
SOMETIMES, VARYING WITH THE
TRUMP
PRESIDENT'S DESCRIPTION.
LET'S BRING IN THE PANEL, CHIEF
POLITICAL CORRESPONDENT AND
MOLLIE HEMINGWAY, SENIOR EDITOR
AT "THE FEDERALIST."
STRUCK BY THE ELECTION FOCUS,
THERE WAS A LOT ON ELECTION
INTERFERENCE.
CHRIS WRAY SAYING NOT ONLY DID
RUSSIA TRY IN 2018, BUT THEY
BELIEVE THAT RUSSIA AND
CHINA ARE GOING TO STEP IT UP IN
2020.
>> I THINK PERHAPS THE SCARIEST
SENTENCE IN THE WHOLE REPORT WAS
THE ONE THAT SAID CHINA AND
RUSSIA ARE MORE ALIGNED THAN AT
ANY POINT IN THE MID-1950s.
THAT IS NOT GOOD AT ALL.
YOU ARE RIGHT ABOUT THE ELECTION
INTERFERENCE.
ON THE OTHER HAND, I THINK WE
HAVE BEEN EXPECTING THIS FOR AT
LEAST FOR TWO YEARS NOW.
ONE OF THE THINGS I THOUGHT WAS
REALLY STRIKING ABOUT THIS
REPORT WAS THAT A LOT OF IT JUST
WASN'T VERY SURPRISING, GIVEN
THE NEWS.
WHEN THE REPORT COMES OUT AND
SAYS THAT NORTH KOREA WANTS TO
BUILD NUCLEAR WEAPONS, AND WANTS
TO BUILD THE MISSILE DELIVERY
SYSTEMS TO ATTACK THE
UNITED STATES OR SOMEWHERE ELSE,
THE SHOCKING THING WOULD'VE BEEN
IF THEY WEREN'T.
THERE IS A LOT OF NEWS IN HERE
THAT WE REALLY ALREADY KNEW.
>> Bret: TO GIVE IT CONTEXT,
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION MAY
POINT BACK TO NORTH KOREA AND
SAY, LISTEN, THEY HAVEN'T FIRED
MISSILES OVER JAPAN, WE'RE STILL
TALKING, AND THEY HAVEN'T TESTED
ANY NEW EXPANDED ARE THEY
DEVELOPING MORE STUFF?
THAT IS WHAT THE INTEL PEOPLE
SAY.
>> THAT IS QUITE DIFFERENT THAN
HIM TWEETING NORTH KOREA IS NO
LONGER A NUCLEAR THREAT.
I THOUGHT IT WAS QUITE A SERIOUS
WARNING.
THEY SAID THAT NORTH KOREA WOULD
NOT GIVE UP ITS NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
SO, THAT IS SETTING THE STAGE
FOR THE UPCOMING MEETING BETWEEN
THE PRESIDENT AND KIM JONG UN.
IT IS GOING TO BE A LOT HARDER
THAN MAYBE DONALD TRUMP THOUGHT
TO GET NORTH KOREA TO MAKE TO
GET THE DEAL HE WANTS.
I THINK YOU HEARD THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE SAY THIS
BEFORE.
REMEMBER RIGHT AFTER HELSINKI
WHEN THEY ALL CAME TO THE
BRIEFING THAT THEY ALL CAME TO
THE WHITE HOUSE TO SAY HOW
SERIOUSLY THEY TOOK A RUSSIAN
AND OTHER COUNTRIES EFFORTS TO
INTERVENE IN ELECTIONS?
THEY HAVE BEEN CLINGING THE
ALARM BELLS FOR QUITE A WHILE.
>> I READ THE REPORT AS WELL,
AND I THOUGHT IT WAS INTERESTING
HOW FREQUENTLY RUSSIA AND CHINA
WERE LINKED TOGETHER AS THE SAME
THREAT.
IT WOULD'VE BEEN NICE TO SEE
WHAT PERCENTAGE COMES FROM
CHINA, WHAT PERCENTAGE FROM
RUSSIA, BECAUSE IT IS HARD TO
DETERMINE WHICH ONE IS THE
GREATER THREAT.
BUT HISTORICALLY SPEAKING, WHAT
THE U.S. HAS ALWAYS TRIED TO DO
IS MAKE SURE THAT RUSSIA AND
CHINA ARE NOT IN CAHOOTS
TOGETHER.
IT IS WAY SOMETIMES YOU ARE
FRIENDLIER TO CHINA AND RUSSIA
KNOWING THAT WHEN THEY WORK
TOGETHER, THAT IS A COMBINED
ADVERSARY THAT IS VERY, VERY
DIFFICULT.
>> WE HAVE ECONOMIC ESPIONAGE
INVESTIGATIONS, FOR EXAMPLE.
THAT IS JUST ONE PIECE OF IT IN
VIRTUALLY EVERY ONE OF OUR 56
FIELD OFFICES.
AND A NUMBER OF THOSE HAVE
PROBABLY DOUBLED OVER THE LAST
THREE OR FOUR YEARS.
ALMOST ALL OF THEM LEAD BACK TO
CHINA.
>> Bret: WHICH IS PRETTY
SUBSTANTIAL.
>> THAT IS REALLY STRIKING, AND
IT IS ONE OF THE THINGS, THAT
CONTRARY TO A LOT OF THE
HEADLINES, THERE WAS NOT A LOT
OF DIFFERENCE WITH THE
PRESIDENT'S POSITION ON THAT.
SO, I MEAN, THERE WAS AN
EMPHASIS ON THE INTEL CHIEFS
COMING OUT AND DISAGREEING WITH
THE PRESIDENT ON ALL THESE
FRONTS, AND YES, THERE WAS SOME
OF THAT --
>> Bret: HERE IS ONE THAT WAS
CLEAR.
THE ISIS DEPICTION AND HOW IT
WAS TALKED ABOUT IS A LOT
DIFFERENT.
>> WE HAVE WON AGAINST ISIS.
WE HAVE BEATEN THEM, AND WE HAVE
BEATEN THEM BADLY.
>> THE GROUP HAS RETURNED TO HIS
GUERRILLA WARFARE TACTICS AND
THREATEN ADVERSARIES WORLDWIDE.
ISIS IS INTENT ON RESEARCHING
AND THREATENS THOUSANDS OF
FIGHTERS IN IRAQ AND SYRIA.
>> AL QAEDA, ISIS, AND THERE
AFFILIATES IN SYRIA AND
AFGHANISTAN CONTINUE TO POSE A
SERIOUS THREAT.
TO SPEAK AT ONE OF THOSE AREAS
WHERE THE PRESIDENT IS SPEAKING
ABOUT WHAT THE ORDERS WERE FOR
THE PENTA
PENTAGON.
THEY WERE TOLD TO MAKE SURE THAT
ISIS DOESN'T CONTROL ALL THE
LAND IT HAS COME A 40,000 SQUARE
MILES.
IN FACT, AS WE SAW TONIGHT, IT
IS DOWN TO ONE COUNT OF ITS
AROUND IT.
NOW IF PEOPLE WANT TO CHANGE
WHAT THE DETERMINATION IS FOR A
WHILE
WHY WE ARE THERE, THEY ARE MORE
THAN WELCOME TO DO THAT.
CONGRESS IS MORE THAN WELCOME TO
MAKE A CASE OF WHY WE SHOULD BE
IN SYRIA FOR UP TO 18 YEARS, AND
MAKE THE CASE THAT THAT
INVOLVEMENT MAKES SENSE AND THAT
EXPENSE OF MONEY AND LIVES IS
SOMETHING THAT IS IN THE U.S.'S
INTERESTS.
BUT AS FAR AS THE QUESTION IS
WHAT WE ACHIEVED WHAT WE SET OUT
TO DO, THERE IS NO QUESTION WE
DID DEFEAT ISIS AS A LANDHOLDER.
>> Bret: THERE IS NOT A LOT OF
NUANCE IN THE PRESIDENT'S
TWITTER FEED WHEN HE SAYS THESE
THINGS.
>> BUT --
>> Bret: THAT THERE IS A LOT
OF DETAIL IN THOSE TESTIMONIES.
>> BUT WHEN IT COMES FROM
HOLDING MILES FROM 40,000 MILES
TO ONE TALENT THAT IS SURROUNDED
BY FIGHTERS, THAT IS OUR